étranger
[Musique]
cadeau de ma vie
je rends visite à ma mère demain
salut Karen c'est maman j'appelle juste pour
dire que je suis tellement tellement excitée de te voir
demain tu es mon ange et je t'aime d'
accord j'aime  tu vas bien au revoir ma chérie je t'aime
tu es à l'aéroport je suis en route je
ne suis pas sûr c'est
ce que tu penses que je devrais faire je suis sûr
que tu feras ce qu'il faut chérie
bienvenue
je t'ai frappé avec  ma voiture
ce que je sais
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est mon petit
moniteur de santé assistant
triste de rentrer à la maison les deux
[Musique] se
sentent totalement irréels
Je suis censé partir Je ne sais pas
si ça va arriver
[Musique]
des
dizaines de kilomètres deviendront des centaines
deviendront des milliers
vos aventures continueront pendant des années
et des années c'est une bonne prise je sais
[Musique]
dévotion
ce n'est pas pour moi
voulez-vous la vérité maintenant
[Musique]